[Music]
sequels Hollywood loves them and film
fans love to complain about them with
Studios desperate to squeeze even the
basest of horror concepts for one more
blood-curdling scare Hollywood sequel
itis has run as rampant in the horror
genre as any other but not every horror
tale is worthy of a sequel and most
sequels fail to live up to the films
that inspired them of course there have
been a few diamonds found in the bloody
mangled rough of horror flick sequels so
let's have a look at some of the
all-time greats scream to reteaming the
cast and crew from 1996's surprise smash
hit scream wes craven and company
basically recycled the same formula for
scream 2 and that meta mix of comedy
mystery and terror is just as fruitful
the second time around it helps that
screenwriter Kevin Williamson
exceedingly well-versed in horror movie
lore crafted another blisteringly
original screenplay for his screen
follow-up many sequels have surpassed
their original yet it succinctly lays
out the rules for a horror movie before
giddily following them to a tee the
result is a film that knows when to make
you laugh when to make you cringe and
yes when to make you scream if only
every sequel aspired to as much aliens
when Ridley Scott brought his space set
chiller alien to the big screen in 1979
the film quite literally changed the
definition of what a horror movie could
be seven years later fresh off the
success of terminator cocky young
director James Cameron released his
hotly anticipated sequel simply titled
aliens to the surprise of fans and
critics alike the film pack just as
visceral punch as its predecessor often
even eclipsing Scott's film in terms of
energy effects and unbridled terror
whether or not you prefer Scott's
claustrophobic slow burn approach to
Cameron's action-packed creature heavy
confection aliens is still widely viewed
not just as one of the greatest horror
sequels ever made but one of the best
sequels ever produced period get away
from her you [ __ ]
Friday the 13th Part two while few would
argue the merits of Friday the 13th is
great cinema even its biggest detractors
have to acknowledge the film's merits as
a great slasher flick that scared up
some unexpectedly impressive box-office
it came as no surprise then that the
film's producers wanted to revisit the
formula in the form of a direct sequel
what was surprising was that they
actually made a better movie the second
time around make no mistake Friday the
13th part two is one of those rare
sequels that actually is better than the
original even if it's set up in
execution are almost identical to the
original it doubles down on the action
resulting in a film that feels bigger
bolder and bloodier than the original it
also happens to feature the debut of one
of slasher domes biggest baddies the one
and only Jason Voorhees Dawn of the Dead
filmmaker George a Romero essentially
invented the zombie genre with his 1968
feature film debut night of the living
dead little did we know Romero was just
scratching the surface when he returned
to the genre with 1978's Dawn of the
Dead viewers were subjected to the full
force of Romero's caustic vision for
hell on earth
with a sequel that included twice as
much blood and gore and a far sharper
satirical edge the perfect storm of
zombie fiction is as shocking to the
eyes as it is to the intellect and
remains one of the greatest zombie
movies sequel or otherwise in history
Wes Craven's new nightmare
a nightmare on elm street is one of the
greatest horror movies ever made but the
same sadly can't be said for the string
of increasingly inferior sequels that
followed it he came as a bit of a
surprise then when Craven himself who
hadn't directed for the franchise since
the original announced his return to Elm
Street with 1994's Wes Craven's new
nightmare that surprise turned to
outright shock when new nightmare turned
out to be the smartest movie in the
franchise the film takes a daringly meta
approach with the formerly dream
stalking Freddy Krueger terrorizing the
real-life cast and crew of the original
film in the real world new nightmare
sort of has no business being as good or
as smart as it is yet it's still easily
the second-best film in the series The
Devil's Rejects Rob Zombie built a
reputation as one of the more intriguing
directors working in the horror genre on
the strength of his debut film the
sadistically stylized house of a
thousand corpses and its equally stylish
sequel The Devil's Rejects behind a
killer classic rock soundtrack and a
razor-sharp screenplay that knows when
to shock and when to pull a laugh
The Devil's Rejects is part Road movie
part revenge thriller and part gory
grindhouse extravaganza that surpasses
its predecessor in almost every way Evil
Dead 2
on paper Sam Raimi's giddily gory
classic evil dead didn't exactly scream
for a sequel even if it was sort of open
for one Evil Dead 2 is essentially the
exact same story as the original and
it's just as gory and grueling as you'd
expect it's also hysterically funny this
go-around with Rainey's deliciously DIY
aesthetic delivering ghoulish gasps and
guffaws you could say they just don't
make them like this anymore but then
again no one besides Raimi ever really
did an Evil Dead to is his one
unmitigated masterpiece thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]